you dear viewer can code in just about
any language you can code Python scripts
you can code Java classes and you can
code in cobal assembler
RPG the only assistance you need comes
from generative AI this prompt here will
work in just about any large language
model generative AI is assisting
software developers of all levels of
experience to write code the user enters
a text prompt describing what the code
should do and generative AI creates the
corresponding code like this and we can
go much further than these examples in
addition to creating new applications
generative AI can help modernize Legacy
code or translate code from one
programming language to another so so
let's explore how this works how this is
different to low and no code and Define
the two broad categories of generative
AI code
generation okay so generative AI for
coding is possible because of
advancements in NLP that's natural
language processing deep learning
algorithms and our good friends large
language models or
llms now these llms are trained on a
vast data set of
existing source
code now the more diverse the source
code the better the the training code
generally comes from publicly available
codes such as those produced by open
source projects although we can also
fine-tune llms with proprietary code
that we feed into the model now here's
how this works programmers enter text
prompts into the llm and this describes
what they want the code to do so uh sort
this row of data or create a submit
button stuff like that and then how they
want the generative AI system to
actually process that now that could be
in the form of a number of different
things so it could be in the form of
code Snippets or it could be all the way
through to full functions of actual code
and this can really streamline the
coding process by handling repetitive
tasks that a human programmer is more
than happy to offload looking at you
error reporting to log files now
generative AI can also translate code
from one language to another something
that's particularly useful in
modernization projects such as updating
Legacy applications by transforming Cobo
to Java it can also serve as a very
efficient method of testing and it's a
great way to perform
debugging now this works best as an
assistant rather than a complete
replacement for human programmers even
as code produced by the generative Ai
and the llm Technologies becomes more
accurate it can still contain flaws and
should be reviewed edited and refined by
actual real life people so we can think
of generative AI as enabling developers
to generate code faster reducing the
work of manually writing lines of code
and freeing developers to focus on
higher value work now I want to pause a
moment to compare all of this to
something called Low and no code
Solutions and to see what the
similarities and differences are now
this is another way to generate code
quickly low and no code tools they're
built on a series of
templates that provide input into this
and they also use a series of
libraries of
components now people without coding
skills can use a visual interface to do
things like drag and drop components to
create applications quickly the code
that this creates is hidden in the
background you don't see it now
generative AI for code on the other hand
doesn't use templates doesn't use
libraries of components the software is
reading the developers plain language
prompts and suggests code Snippets from
scratch that will produce the desired
results so while low code and no code
tools generally Target non-developers
and business users both Pro developers
and other users can use AI code
generation software all right so let's
finally put generative AI code into two
categories I think we can think of this
in in two different ways and the first
way I would consider is
general
purpose so we're talking here about
general purpose generative AI
applications and that encompasses stuff
like chat GPT and Google B and depending
on their training data set most of these
llms can perform some level of coding
based on text proms but these are
freestanding tools rather than
integrated plugins that work Direct ly
in the developer's own
environment that is the second category
so we can think of the second category
really as being code generation
tools these are tools dedicated
specifically to creating code rather
than these general purpose ones which
address a much broader area so for
example we can think of GitHub co-pilot
that's a pre-trained AI model and code
completion tool that writes code in many
languages including JavaScript go Pearl
Ruby Swift the the list goes on it it
uses machine learning to suggest code
based on context can analyze code for
vulnerabilities and is available for as
an extension for various idees including
Visual Studio code and there's also IBM
Watson X code assistant that helps
developers write code using AI generated
recommendations it provides pre-trained
curated models based on specific
programming languages ultimately
generative AI for code is a valuable
tool in code Creation in code
translation testing and debugging and
best of all it's opening up who can
contribute to the software development
process if you have any questions please
drop us a line below and if you want to
see more videos like this in the future
please like And subscribe thanks for
watching